the important thing to do with a lot of  these classics like the Carll sweater is  turn it a little bit on its head wear it  in a different way where with you know  something a little bit unexpected  you don't want to look traditional head  to toe you want something there the  throws it off in fall you need a little  bit of pattern you need a little bit of  fanciness it's got that heritage  I love it when you wear it underneath  the duffle coat I love it under a jean  jacket I think it's great by itself with  a chambray shirt underneath and a pair  of khakis or corduroys can pull a lot of  those colors out another thing to  remember about a Farrell sweaters to  pick one that's cut trim because there  are still a few leftovers out there this  is definitely something you don't want  to buy in the old man's store